you can walk talk stab shoot and maim
since the late 80s the murderous Chucky
doll has remained an essential part of
Horror's iconography today we're ranking
the foul mouth Toy's most famous film
appearances from worst to best
rounding out a Trilogy of films in 1991
Child's Play 3 wasn't exactly Chucky's
greatest moment the story had so many
parallels to the first two a Chucky once
again tracking down his obsession from
the previous films Andy Barkley now a
teenager Andy is in military school and
Chucky wants to complete their
unfinished business the film showcases a
bit of corporate greed as the toy
company behind the good guy dolls seeks
to capitalize off the toy despite the
bad press that resulted from the Barkley
incident the factory and assets are
still in hand it seems and the toys seem
to be very profitable for the company
before the incident so unfortunately for
his victims Chucky was born again
instead of following through with the
objective of transferring to Seoul into
teenage Andy's body Chucky realizes he
has a new body and can once again
possess the first person who learns his
true nature therefore he shifts Focus to
an eight-year-old Cadet attending the
same military school by the name of
Ronald Tyler when Andy understands
what's happening and sees a good guy
doll he does everything in his power to
protect young Ronald from becoming
Charles Lee Ray's host ultimately Andy
overpowers a Serial killing doll by
throwing him into a fan that slices him
to bits of course after seeing Chucky's
previous demise audiences never believed
that his destruction here would keep the
deranged killer down forever
of all the films in the child's play
franchise seat of Chucky may have taken
itself the least seriously showing us
that plastic dolls can conceive and bear
children Chucky and his former flame
Tiffany set out to start Life as a
family once they learn of their son
Glenn who recently escaped an abusive
Master Tiffany voiced by Jennifer Tilly
wants a normal family life but Chucky
can't resist the urge to maim and murder
even expressing that he wants her son to
partake in the family business
I'm not gonna let you poison our son's
mind with your touchy feely 12-step bull
Glenn however isn't quite like his old
man instead he's kind-hearted and
benevolent for this reason Tiffany makes
Chucky agree to stop killing however
Crossing his fingers behind his back
Chucky shows us what we already know a
leopard never changes its spots in an
astonishing turn of events Glenn turns
out to actually have two personalities
one is the timid Glenn shown earlier in
the film and the other is the ravenous
soul of his sister Glenda who is more
than happy to spill a little blood when
Glenn sees what his sister has done
while in control of his body it's a
horrifying Revelation to him but an
unsurprising one for the audience given
the young doll's parentage aside from
voicing Tiffany Jennifer Tilly also
plays a dramatized version of herself in
the film after her character becomes
pregnant with Chucky's child the
pregnancy speeds up at a rapid Pace
thanks to the magic at work behind
Chucky's entire being and a rather fun
coincidence she Bears twins a boy and a
girl in the final moments of the film we
learned that Tiffany Glenn and Glenda
have all transferred their souls into
Jennifer and her two infant children
while Chucky has an epiphany and decides
he enjoys being an evil doll in defense
of his mother Glenda decapitates Chucky
in his first truly violent act however
the audience once again knows better
than to assume this is the end of the
murderous doll Chucky always returns
the precursor to Seed of Chucky Bride of
Chucky depicted the origins of Chucky
and Tiffany's murderous relationship
after Chucky's destruction at the end of
Child's Play 3 a human Tiffany bribes
and murders a police officer in order to
obtain the pieces of Chucky's body and
reassemble them an ex-girlfriend of
Charles Lee Ray Tiffany performs some
Voodoo incantations to try to revive her
former lover she manages to bring
Chucky's soul back into the doll and
Alive once again he proceeds to kill the
first person he sees still enamored with
Rey's Spirit Tiffany brings up an
engagement ring that was found on his
body assuming he was planning to propose
to her not the romantic type Chucky
laughs off the idea and states that the
ring was simply something he stole
angered by his callous disregard for her
love and loyalty Tiffany traps him in a
cage but Chucky frees himself and
electrocutes her while she's in a
bathtub he then places her soul on a
bride doll she had in her possession
with her death Chucky creates a new
partner in crime as they both seek out
human bodies to take over the film took
on a more humorous approach than its
predecessors focusing on black comedy
instead of the Frights and jump scares
of the past Child's Play films
went out with Bundy and Dahmer you look
like Martha Stewart with that thing
whereas Andy was a lead character in the
prior films a narrative and Bride of
Chucky is focused on the dolls
themselves and their unsuspecting human
prey amount to only supporting roles
in the second Child's Play film The ever
persistent play Pals company reassembles
a good guide doll with tight quality
control in an effort to show the public
that no harm was done due to the events
of the previous film unfortunately one
of the workers is electrocuted during
the rebuilding process and the CEO
forcefully tells his underlings to
suppress the event meanwhile Andy is
forced to live in a foster home and his
mother is institutionalized in a mental
treatment facility after the horrific
events of the first film of course
Chucky escapes the play Palace factory
after the company unknowingly resurrects
him and it quickly tracks down Andy to
try to take over his body Chucky
eventually attempts to complete the
ritual of transferring his soul to Andy
however he realizes he is incapable of
doing so and angrily sets out to kill
the little boy Andy with the help of his
foster sister Kyle eventually gets the
better of the evil doll Child's Play 2
was considered a major success and even
took the top spot at the box office in
its first weekend in theaters due to the
success of the first two films Chucky
was officially solidified as a horror
icon with a bright future ahead at least
in theory
Coulter Chucky was the second of two
direct video films in the franchise
following Curse of Chucky somewhat
surprisingly it turned out to be a
perfectly decent horror film despite
never being screened in theaters
following seat of Chucky the series
shifted back into horror mode which
Chucky once again acting as he only
possessed doll hiding in the shadows
following the events of Curse of Chucky
and adult Andy Barkley keeps the head of
Chucky on a pike taking pleasure and
constantly torturing the crazed killer
within the doll is retribution for his
sins but Andy doesn't know is that
Chucky has found a way to split his soul
among multiple dolls for the four years
following the events of the previous
film Nika Pierce spent her days in a
mental institution convinced that a doll
murdered her family her psychiatrist Dr
Foley convinces her that she committed
the murders and an episode of psychosis
and that her memories of Chucky were
merely a way for her brain to cope after
the doctor introduces a good guy doll
into his Patient Group in an effort to
help aid in her healing process funny
business begins all over again to make
matters worse two more good guy dolls
are eventually introduced to the
facility and Chucky possesses all of
them the idea of multiple Chuck cookies
causing havoc and wreaking Terror on the
patients within the Asylum offers
Unapologetic Primal Thrills and brought
the franchise into new territory in an
interview with collider writer and
director Don Mancini stated I didn't
really know how I would do it
dramatically but I just knew that the
image of a bunch of Chuckies was cool I
felt that at this point in the franchise
it was time to do it a new Direction
worked garnering the film largely
positive reviews from critics listen to
you you sound like cannibal Lecter I
can't believe they canceled that show
in the age of reboots and remakes
Child's Play landed one of its own in
2019. the story Revisited the Barkley
family made famous by the original 1988
film but the Remake did away with the
serial killer Soul trapped in a doll's
body Trope and modernized the premise by
examining AI technology gone awry
instead of the good guy dolls the
company has now introduced to Buddy
dolls while they look remarkably similar
to the original Chucky doll they feature
added robotic elements part of the new
iteration of the doll's revolutionary
technology is that it is supposed to
imprint on the child learning Its
Behavior so they can play together the
start of the film sees a disgruntled
factory worker get fired he ends his
life but before doing so he sticks it to
the company in a final Act by unlocking
the safety protocols around one of the
dolls in the production line this
decision allows its AI to operate free
of restriction ultimately resulting in
chaos at first Chucky seeks Andy's
approval but he comes to believe he can
best protect Andy through violent means
eventually Andy comes to realize that
the doll has blood on his hands and he
has to figure out how to rein in the
murderous robot as one would fact
everything gets out of hand and the
final moments of the third act turn into
a bloody nightmare befitting the child's
play name
nearly a decade after the release of
Seed of Chucky Don Mancini breed new
life into the serial killing doll
franchise with Curse of Chucky the film
took the little slasher back to his
horror Roots by placing him in the home
of a new unsuspecting family The Pierces
after receiving the doll by mysterious
means the Pierce's matriarch Sarah dies
under strange circumstances while her
passing was ultimately ruled as a
suicide her daughter Nika suspects a
doll after doing her own research on
good guy and their connection with
serial killer Charles Lee Ray Chucky
soon makes himself known and Nika does
everything within her power to stop him
in typical Chucky fashion however the
majority of the family fights the dust
before attempting to kill Nika Chucky
tells her the reason he came to her home
and murdered her entire family prior to
the events of the original film Charles
Lee Ray was infatuated with Nico's then
pregnant mother Sarah Rey eventually
kidnapped Sarah to have her for himself
and as the police arrived on the scene
he stabbed her causing Nika to be born
handicapped it was after this murder
that the police pursued Rey and cornered
him in the toy store where he was shot
and killed but not before transferring
his soul into a Chucky doll all of this
clever revisionism is meant to present
the classic 1988 film in a new light
with an expanded universe these creative
decisions were evidently successful as
it has become one of the most critically
renowned installments of the franchise
the horror of Chucky all began in 1988
with the release of the original Child's
Play The film's enduring Legacy is
largely due to its terrifying Twist on
horror an evil child's toy transforming
from a Charming play thing to an
unsettling murder machine
hi
it's me Chucky what do you think
well the idea of a possessed doll wasn't
entirely new at the time it hadn't quite
made it into the mainstream either after
dedicating a feature-length film to the
concept audiences were shocked by the
trash talking bloodlusting doll powered
by a soul attempting to cheat death but
unable to resist its intrinsic urge to
kill after murderer Charles E Ray meets
his own demise at the hands of pursuing
law enforcement he grabs the nearest
object a good guy doll and performs a
voodoo spell transferring his soul into
its body before his own mortal flesh
expires from its wounds of course young
Andy Barkley is the unfortunate
recipient of the corrupted doll Chucky
reveals himself to Andy stopping at
nothing to transfer Soul into the
child's body while trying to kill anyone
who gets in his way the film received
High Praise from renowned critics such
as Roger Ebert who wrote Child's Play is
a cheerfully energetic horror film of
the slam Bank school but Slicker and
more clever than most the movie also
made big money at the box office despite
carrying a limiting R rating becoming
one of the highest grossing films of
1988. Child's Play left an indelible
mark on the horror genre and all these
decades later we all know that Chucky
will be back again a true best friend
till the end
[Music]